- [Instructor] We're told that Polygon Q
is a scaled copy of Polygon P
using a scale factor of one half.
Polygon Q's area is what
fraction of Polygon P's area?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
Alright, my brain wants to
make this a little bit tangible
and once we get some
practice, you might be able
to do it without drawing pictures
but they're saying some
arbitrary Polygon Q and P
so let's just make a simple one.
Since we're talking about
area, I like to deal
with rectangles since it's easy to think
about areas of rectangles.
And so, let's see, Polygon Q
is a scaled copy of Polygon P.
So let's start with Polygon P.
And I will do this in red.
So Polygon P, let's just say,
I'm just gonna create
an arbitrary polygon.
So let's say that this is,
and I'm gonna scale it by one half
so I'm gonna make its sides
have nice even numbers.
So let's say this side
right over here is four
and this side right over
here is equal to eight,
this is Polygon P right over
here, it's a quadrilateral,
it's in fact a rectangle
and its area is just going
to be four times eight
which is 32.
Now let's create Polygon Q, and remember,
Polygon Q is a scaled copy of P
using a scale factor of one half.
So we're gonna scale it by one half.
So instead of this side being
four, it's going to be two
and instead of this side
over here being eight,
the corresponding side
in the scaled version
is going to be four.
So there you go, we've
scaled it by one half,
and now what is our area going to be?
Well our area, and this Polygon Q,
and so our area is going
to be two times four
which is equal to eight.
So notice that Polygon
Q's area is one fourth
of Polygon P's area and that makes sense
because when you scale the dimensions
of the Polygon by one half,
the area is going to change
by the square of that.
One half squared is one fourth
and so the area has been changed
by a factor of one fourth
or another way to answer this question,
Polygon Q's area is what
fraction of Polygon P's area?
Well it's going to be one
fourth of Polygon P's area.
And the big takeaway here
is if you scale something,
if you scale the sides of
a figure by one half each,
then the area is going
to be the square of that
and so one half squared is one over four.
If it was scaled by one third,
then the area would be scaled, or the area
would be one ninth.
If it was scaled by a factor of two,
then our area would have
grown by a factor of four.
Let's do another example.
Here we're told, Rectangle N has an area
of five square units.
Let me do this in a different color.
So Rectangle N has an
area of five square units.
James drew a scaled version of Rectangle N
and labeled it Rectangle P.
So they have that right over here.
This is a scaled version of Rectangle N.
What scale factor did James use
to go from Rectangle N to Rectangle P?
So let's think about it.
They gave us Rectangle P right over here,
and let's think about its dimensions.
This height is one,
two, three, four, five,
it's five high, and it
is, one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine wide,
and so its area is equal to 45.
Now, Rectangle N had an
area of five square units.
So our area, let me write this down,
so N area to P area,
N area to P area, we are
multiplying by a factor of nine.
If we're going from an
area of five square units
to 45 square units, you
notice N area is five,
N's area is five square units, P's area,
we just figured out is 45 square units,
and so we have it growing
by a factor of nine.
Now what would be the
scale factor if our area
grew by a factor of nine?
Well we just talked about
the idea that area will grow,
the factor with which area grows
is the square of the scale factor.
So one way to think
about it is scale factor,
scale factor squared
is going to be equal to nine,
or another way to think about it,
our scale factor is going
to be equal to three
to go from N to P.
Now let's verify that we
answered their question
but I just want us to feel good about it.
Let's draw a rectangle
that is scaled down from P
by a factor of three.
So a rectangle if we were to scale it up
by a factor of three, we get rectangle P.
So its bottom would have
length three instead of nine.
So it'd be like this.
So that would be three, and its height
instead of being five,
it would be five thirds.
Five thirds is one and two thirds,
so it'd go about that high,
it would look something like that.
It would be five thirds.
And so our Rectangle N
would look like this,
and what is its area?
Well five thirds times three
is indeed five square units.
So notice, when we have the area growing
by a factor of nine, the
scale factor of the size
to go from five thirds to
five, you multiply by three.
To go from three to nine,
you multiply by three.